hi this is steve kaufman here uh today i
want to talk about how i learned
ukrainian
now i have been doing most of my videos
in my little studio but today i'm going
to do it in front of this painting and
i'm going to tell you why but first of
all if you enjoy my videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a comment
so before i get into talking about how i
learned ukrainian i'll explain why i'm
doing it in front of this
painting here this is a print of course
it's not an original
it is uh
what it's called
or plus
painted by the terrace you know painted
by van gogh van gogh in english the
famous
dutch impressionist painter
and i like doing it in front of this
picture because it has the ukrainian
colors the blue and the yellow
plus i very much like this print
and
you know van gaal van gogh was a dutch
painter he spent a lot of time in france
southern france also in normandy
and as someone that is interested in
languages you won't be surprised to know
that i kind of like the mixture of
cultures and even in food you know
olive oil with my sushi or
wasabi with my french food or what
whatever i like mixing things and
similarly i like mixing cultures and i
like the way one culture leads you to
another
uh and by exploring all these different
cultures you learn more and more about
the world and my discovery of ukrainian
and ukraine is a good example
so
for most of my life
i knew next to nothing about ukraine i
think like a lot of people i thought it
was some kind of appendage to russia
similar to russia
and i didn't know much more than that
uh in 2000 and i would say six or seven
i started learning russian
largely
to see whether i could learn a slavic
language with all the complicated
grammar
uh without spending a lot of time on
grammar so that was that plus having
read you know tolstoy and dostoyevsky in
my
late teens i thought it would be cool to
read it in the original russian
so i was with russian learning russian
enjoying russian listening to russian
audiobooks reading on link
and
of course in 2008 there was the war in
georgia which i followed because i
followed ekamuskri much to the
disappointment of many russians who are
caught up in the sort of propaganda
world that has been created in russia
they're the only good people in the
world everybody else is mean to them
and echo must be was kind of tolerated
as sort of a safety valve for a variety
of opinions
a lot of these opinions were critical of
the government but you also had the
communist party would be
interviewed and the you know
whatever his name was i can't remember
gennady i can't remember
and um
extreme
uh imperialist types like uh
i think it's uh
prokhorov or prohanov was on there
at any rate so russia invaded georgia
i didn't pay much attention
2010 there was an election in ukraine
and yanukovych won
and of course the russians were
following that very closely but still it
was all
far away i didn't pay much attention
then in 2014
russia
took crimea
and i watched that and someone told me
that i could follow these events on
ukrainian television so i started
watching a program called schuster live
and lo and behold on shuster live
half the people speak russian or spoke
russian half the people spoke ukrainian
and as i was listening to the ukrainian
i felt as though i should be able to
understand it but i couldn't understand
it very strange feeling because it's
pronounced in many ways kind of sounds
like russian but in fact so many of the
words are different
so
uh
i decided that i would learn ukrainian
and
uh the
i bought some books on starter books and
also uh radio free europe uh out of
prague
uh was putting out radios faboda svoboda
in ukrainian put out regular
interviews
um
where they had both audio and text so
knowing russian and and what i
discovered was that like half the words
are like 60 of the words are like
russian
and so if i had you know audio material
with transcript then i could import that
in the link
and very quickly
i could acquire new words i think my
vocabulary account on link in ukrainian
is like 50 or 60 000 known words
because so many words you can guess what
they mean
a few you have to learn
and i just listened i can't imagine i
think i've read one and a half million
words of ukrainian on link i don't know
how many hours i've listened to in fact
i'll show you uh in fact let me show you
my profile in russian which shows that i
begin around 2007 and then you'll see my
profile on ukrainian which shows that i
begin around 2014 and you can see where
i have been most active in those
languages
so
listening to all this stuff and also
romanski radio
which is a very
good source of audio of of podcasts
but without transcript so it was only
after training myself on the radio free
europe material that i was good enough
to understand
a lot of the
podcasts on romance radio most of which
were in ukrainian some of which were in
russian so i was able to follow the
events in the donbass but let's go back
to crimea so i followed the events there
uh
initially russia claimed that the little
green men with no military insignia were
not their soldiers which of course was
not true
putin subsequently admitted that yes
there you know at first he said oh they
just bought those are just people who
went and bought
military uh
uniforms at some store
and then he admitted that they were in
fact russian soldiers
and the events in crimea
were planned by a group of agents
borrowed
who subsequently went to the dunbas
and took what was a quite a volatile
situation and turned it into a war and i
followed this
daily
uh i followed it as uh you know the the
people in the donbass and stepping back
obviously there was a lot of tension you
could see this at schuster live you had
the representatives of the sort of
pro-russian faction you had uh
the the right-wing more nationalistic
types like the head of parties for boda
you had this guy leshko who is a bit of
a nut case also a a right-wing extremist
you had everybody and you had people who
are subsequently subsequently identified
as being corrupt
you know you had this sense of ukraine
is follow these people who are very
eloquent and speak with great passion
and a tremendous range of opinions and
in schuster live as they speak the
people in the audience vote on what they
think of what they're saying there
so it was about obviously a period of
tremendous tension
because of the events of the maidan
which had brought in
a
government
which was voted by all parties by the
way
uh which was more pro-western
it was more sort of pro-nationalist
than the previous government under
yanukovych and there were people in
eastern ukraine who didn't want that
these are people who had voted for
yanukovych their guy fled
so obviously they're upset i'm watching
this in ukrainian
every day following it
if i get my uh
podcast from uh radio radios faboda i've
now got a text so i'm very interested in
the subject i'm following it as uh you
know gear ken is the first
minister of war for the dunbas uh what
they call themselves the dunyas people's
republic borodai is the
i think prime minister of the dunyas
people's republic there's a guy called
bessler who is some kind of a sleeping
russian gru agent that's
been living there and he organizes you
know militia and so they go from
storming government buildings to
eventually having some kind of an armed
force there's a war the ukrainian
army is very poorly organized between
the ukrainian army and volunteers
largely from eastern ukraine
they fight back they're able to
eventually
arrive at a sort of a a cease-fire line
after the intervention of the russian
regular russian army to prevent the
ukrainian army from actually taking back
that whole area there were people killed
on both sides mostly soldiers
ukrainian
ukrainian government soldiers volunteers
on the ukrainian side
the uh separatist fighters on the other
side russian soldiers from assatya
wherever they came
yakuta there was quite a few sort of
mongolian types
there
who were
shown and you know some of them were in
hospital with severe
but serious burns and so forth
a very unhappy situation
a lot of people fled displaced people to
other parts of ukraine some fled to
russia
total death toll is supposedly around 15
000. i followed it every day and so i
with that my ukrainian comprehension
improved
now
uh at some point i said i should start
speaking ukrainian very difficult to do
because i'm so used to speaking russian
but i had a russian tutor who was
actually from ukraine
and so slowly slowly i started speaking
ukrainian with her
she subsequently emigrated to the united
states with her husband and family
and then i found two more tutors one in
leviev and one in nipro
the one in nipro
eventually
at some point
with all of the the
shelling going on back and forth across
the demarcation line and people living
uh without gas without water i said i
want to do something to help those
people so
uh
my uh
ukrainian tutor in nepro introduced me
to the small non-governmental
organization in krasnojorfka which is a
suburb of the city of daniels and every
quarter i sent the money so that they
could buy
you know diapers for old people we built
kitchens for school for a school
a little park we did a whole bunch of
stuff to improve the quality of life of
those people i eventually did visit was
very well received kids were singing and
dancing and i got the bread and salt
treatment and
and most people in eastern ukraine speak
russian but some of them do speak
ukrainian
so i went there i was also in kiev and
then i was in lev which is a wonderful
city and again when we're talking about
the sort of connections of of languages
and peoples
one of the
other aside from um
another major source of my uh listening
and reading in ukrainian was the history
of ukraine and i have a number of these
um
audiobooks e-books i in particular liked
leonid
zaliznyak
and so i listened and listened and
listened and read in ukrainian i
discovered
lo and behold
what i didn't realize that ukraine
had a history which involved the
original kievan rus which involved being
invaded by the mongols
which then involved them
being conquered by the lithuanians who
were welcomed by the ukrainians because
they were pushing back against the
mongols
that eventually become becomes the
lithuanian polish or polish lithuanian
commonwealth
the poles
are uh but but there's a whole history
of of interaction between ukrainians and
poles and so that the vocabulary in
ukrainian
is closer to polish i don't know if the
polls influence the ukrainian language
or the ukrainians influence the polish
language or they all came from some
church slavonic i have no idea but the
fact is that from a vocabulary point of
view
russian is a bit of an outlier
and the ukrainian and polish and even
check vocabulary are closer
however
all of a sudden i began seeing you know
and then you have uh
the polls were
kind of trying to force the ukrainians
to become catholic which the ukrainians
resisted and there was a whole bunch of
unpleasantness
resulting eventually in the melitzki
rebellion where
basically everything to the east of the
nepa river went over to zara's russia
with the promise of some independence
which turned out not to be the case
i only mentioned this because
my learning of ukrainian involved
following the day-to-day events
in ukraine and also learning a great
deal about the history and so then when
i visited levive
so here you are in la viv again if we
talk about fusion of cultures and so
forth
leve
before the war before the second world
war was 50 polish 30 percent jewish 20
ukrainian because the ukrainian speakers
lived in the countryside
and lev
which was known to the germans as
lemberg and to the polls as lev
was the fourth largest city in the
austro-hungarian empire and so you see
in la viv the sort of
evidence of these different
national historical religious you know
buildings there's even an armenian
church there
uh and so again it's this sort of
blending of cultures and
another thing that i i firmly believe is
that the our culture and our language is
not in our dna
so
there are lots of people in russia who
have ukrainian family names that doesn't
mean that they're ukrainian there are
lots of people in ukraine who have
russian family names who may even have
russian
parents or grandparents who may even
speak russian in fact half the
ukrainians speak russian
more often than they speak ukrainian
from what i can gather whether it's 50
50 60 40 i don't know but those people
identify as ukrainians so the dna is not
the issue it's it's what you want to be
that is the issue
and that's kind of part of the problem
right now that the russians are not
prepared to accept that regardless of
the dna of individual ukrainians they in
their majority not all majority want to
identify as ukrainian want to have a
separate existence as ukrainian and
their language is well worth learning
and i have never believed that there are
great languages in small languages like
after russian i learned czech czech has
10 million speakers russian has a
hundred and who knows 180 million
speakers it doesn't matter
every language is wonderful it's
beautiful there is no more beautiful
language more important language greater
language it's whatever you want to learn
and as you learn that you discover a
whole bunch of things about that
language culture place history that you
didn't know before that's been my
experience with every language that i
have learned
and i'm discovering it now with arabic
and persian and a little bit of turkish
that i've done
so
you know it's a little bit of a
disjointed rant here following up on the
video where i said we're offering free
ukrainian
on link to anyone who wants to learn
ukrainian and free access to link to all
ukrainians refugees or resident in
ukraine
i should point out that that offer is
valid for all refugees
uh so i'm hoping that syrians and
afghans will
take advantage
as of today i think we have 3 600
ukrainians who have approached support
at link to get free access to link
i'm hoping that other refugees will also
do that and we're going to produce
tutorials
in ukrainian and also sahara at lincoln
help to provide a farsi
version of these tutorials for afghan
refugees who speak farsi and hopefully
we can do the same in syrian arabic or
even in standard arabic
and in pashtu if we can find people to
help us with those versions
so a bit again i tend to wander on these
i hope that's of interest a little bit
long maybe
but um
that's how i got involved with ukrainian
i've probably forgotten a few oh i
should yes
one of the things i did when i went to
lev where i met with my online tutor
solomia
and we set up a system whereby she took
me around levi
we visited churches and cafes and
and
cemeteries and all different things that
you know monasteries
and we would just speak ukrainian and
she would
type up in her little cell phone
all of the
errors that i made in terms of you you
know usage and phrases and and words and
she would then send them to me by email
i would import that into link and study
it so we did that from nine to twelve i
go back to my room i study it go back to
two o'clock and two to five and we did
that for five days and that is a
tremendous way
to discover the city of la vie and also
to work on my ukrainian
so i forgot about that uh something i
would recommend in fact when i was in
kiev i was thinking boy it would be
great to be able to connect with a tutor
and say look i want you to take me
around keith we're going to speak
ukrainian or russian whatever the case
may be
three hours in the morning maybe just
morning
and then i can study all of that and we
go back to it the next day and the next
day and the next day so and we could do
that in italian in spanish or chinese or
japanese wherever you are
sort of integrating that
one-on-one contact with a tutor and yet
then getting the sort of text of the
problems you had studying the mont link
and going back to it again the next day
anyway thank you for listening i hope it
wasn't too long
and i'll leave you with a couple of
videos where
i um
talk about ukraine and speak ukrainian
thanks for listening bye for now